in my first few days in the job I've
held extensive discussions with the
Prime Minister cabinet colleagues the
governor of the bank of England the obr
the head of the debt management office
treasury officials and many others
the conclusion I've drawn from those
conversations is that we need to do more
more quickly to give certainty to the
markets about our fiscal plans and show
through action and not just words that
the United Kingdom can and always will
pay our way in the world
we've therefore decided to make further
changes to the mini budget immediately
rather than waiting until the
medium-term fiscal plan in two weeks
time in order to reduce unhelpful
speculation about those plans
Mr Speaker I'm very grateful for your
agreement
on the need to give the markets an early
brief summary this morning but I welcome
the opportunity to give this house
details of those decisions now
we've decided on the following changes
to support confidence and stability
firstly the Prime Minister and I agreed
yesterday to reverse almost all the tax
measures announced in the growth plan
three weeks ago that have not been
legislated for in Parliament so we will
continue with the abolition of the
Health and Social care Levy changes to
stamp Duty the increase in the annual
investment allowance to a million pounds
and The Wider reforms to investment
taxes but we will no longer be
proceeding with the cuts to Dividend tax
rates saving around a billion pounds a
year the reversal of the off payroll
working reforms introduced in 2017 and
2021 saving around 2 billion pounds a
year the new vat-free shopping scheme
for non-uk visitors saving a further two
billion pounds a year or the freeze on
alcohol Duty rates saving around 600
million pounds a year
second the government is currently
committed to cutting the basic rate of
income tax to 19 in April of 2023 it is
a deeply held conservative value a value
that I share that people should keep
more of the money they earn which is why
we have continued with the abolition of
the Health and Social care level
but at a time when markets are asking
serious questions about our commitment
to sound public finances we cannot
afford a permanent discretionary
increase in borrowing worth 6 billion
pounds a year so I've decided that the
basic rate of income tax will remain at
20 and it will do so indefinitely until
economic circumstances allow for it to
be cut
taken together with the decision not to
cut corporation tax and restoring the
top rate of income tax the measures I've
announced today will raise around 32
billion pounds every year
the third step I'm taking today Mr
Speaker is to review the energy price
guarantee
that was the biggest single expense in
the growth plan and one of the most
generous schemes in the world it's a
landmark policy for which I pay tribute
to my predecessor my right honorable
friend from spellthore and we'll support
millions of people through a difficult
winter reducing inflation by up to five
percent so I confirmed today that the
support we are providing between now and
April next year will not change
but beyond next April the Prime Minister
and I have reluctantly agreed it would
not be responsible to continue exposing
the public finances to unlimited
volatility in international gas prices
so I'm announcing today a treasury-led
review into how we support energy bills
Beyond April next year